When I was a child,
I was about eight years old,
and I went to climb on a house
that was under construction
in our neighbourhood.
So I stepped up to the edge
and I fell,
and the fall seemed
to take a very long time,
so then I was looking down
at the ground watching
the red brick floor come towards me
and once I hit the ground
then I went unconscious but it got
me interested in the question of...
When I grew up and
I became a neuroscientist,
what I realised was we all come
into the world with this idea
that time is just a river that’s
flowing forward in one direction
at a fixed speed, but what we know
is that it can be different
in your head and in my head,
because it's somehow
a psychological construct, time.
In other words, your brain is locked
in silence and darkness
inside the vault of your skull
and its job is to figure out
what's happening outside but
it has to do a lot of editing tricks.
Your vision and your hearing
process signals at different speeds
and yet, when you see
something like a balloon pop
or somebody clapping their hands,
it appears as though the sight
and sound are synchronised.
And what that means is the brain has
to be collecting all the information
before it puts together a final
story and serves that up
to your conscious perception.
It's like there's a buffer where
it looks for other signals
coming up the pipeline
and as a result
it means that we're all living
a little bit in the past.
What we think is happening right
now has actually already transpired
some time ago, probably in the
ballpark of about half a second ago.
In the lab if I show you a photograph
for half a second on the screen
and then I show you that same
photograph again for half a second
and then again and again and again.
And now I show you
a different photograph
for the same amount of time,
it will seem as though the new
photograph, the oddball,
stays on the screen
for a much longer time.
Essentially when the brain
sees something that's novel,
it has to burn more energy
to represent it
because it wasn't expecting that.
This feeling that things are going in
slow motion is a trick of memory.
In other words, when you're
in an emergency situation
a part of the brain called
the amygdala comes online,
this is your emergency
control centre,
it lays down memories on what
amounts to a secondary memory track,
these are very dense memories.
And you're noticing everything
around you and writing it all down.
So when the brain
reads that back out,
there's such a density
of memory there,
that the brain's only conclusion is
that must have taken a long time.
And I think this offers an
explanation for why people think
that time seems to speed up
as they grow older.
And it's because when you’re a child,
everything's new to you.
You're figuring out
the rules of the world,
you're writing down a lot of memory,
and so when you look back
at the end of a year,
you have a lot of memory
of what you've learnt.
But when you're much older and
you look back at the end of the year,
you're probably doing approximately
the same stuff you've been doing
for the X number of previous years.
And so it seems like the year
just went by in a flash.
Really the way to feel as though
you've lived longer
is to seek novelty.
So you can start
with something simple
like putting your wristwatch
on your other hand
or brushing your teeth
with your other hand.
Something this simple just forces
the brain into a new mode
where it can't predict exactly
what's going to happen
but instead has to be engaged.
And what that means is when
you go to bed at night time
you have a lot of footage
to draw upon
and it feels like your life
is lasting longer.
Thanks for watching :)
Don’t forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos. See you again soon!